all right here with reaction to all the
breaking news yeah Robert Muller agreed
to testify former independent counsel
they changed the law to the special
counsel law can stars with us you worked
under a very different sir a very
different circumstances you didn't have
an option as it relates to testifying
the issue of you're compelled to release
this interestingly it was people like
Jerry Nadler who didn't want your report
to be public although the law compelled
it and you took a lot of heat if I
recall correctly mr. Starr for doing
your job that's exactly right
Sean it was for me the longest day back
in November of 1998 and I think Bob
Muller is going to now I have a very
similar experience and there will be
just as there were for me from the
Democratic side of the aisle at the time
there's going to be as you've been
saying and Senator Graham was saying
there's no be very hard questions for
Bob Muller and that's right that's the
way it should be I should have caught up
to testify and Bob Muller should go up
to testify that greatly respect senator
Graham's over but in light of the fact
that some 70 Democrats in the House of
Representatives are crying for an
impeachment inquiry this is a logical
step and I think it's going to be an
important day for the American people
yeah well I I do think there are some
very very tough difficult questions for
Bob Muller I don't understand
for the life of me with that broad
mandate as I've been saying fairer
violations decades old taxes yeah by the
way everyone pay your taxes don't lie
alone applications we got it don't lie
under oath but how do you ignore a
bought and paid for
Russian dossier that was leaked to the
American people by we believed the
intelligence community to impact the
election Russian lies whose own author
says he can't he didn't know if any of
its true which makes it unverifiable but
becomes the basis to spy on not only
Carter page
there was other spying abroad but the
Trump campaign transition and presidency
now that was all based on unverifiable
based on the own author how did he
ignore that sir right well it's a very
good question and I think what Bob
father will say is look this was handed
to me I didn't have occasion to go back
and look at how it came to me just hey
here's the job now go do the job as
opposed to look at the background of the
job again I think these are fair
questions that you're raising Shawn
there's so many questions about the
investigation itself why they wear for
you've raised some of them here tonight
and I think it's going to be a really an
important day I keep coming back to the
concept of accountability because when
Bob Mahler held his press conference but
didn't take questions I think we should
be concerned about that why won't you
respond to questions from the press and
now I think it's most appropriate like
those are one of the people's house I
think both sides of the aisle Democrats
Republicans wanted this and I'm glad
that it's that it's going to happen do
you think it's a hard time answering the
people he appointed Weissman how do you
appoint Hillary Clinton's attorney how
do you only point Democrats no
Republican donors
how does he answer that yeah
and I've raised concerns about that
really from the get-go and just very
briefly Shawn when questions were raised
back during my investigation that oh
you're a Republican I reached out
specifically to the other side of the
aisle because the appearance of fairness
and even-handedness in the
administration justice it's very very
important so we brought in Sam - of
Watergate played on the Democratic side
we brought in a deputy in the night
council terrific guy
Mike Chui who registered Democrats voted
for President Clinton and it's important
give the public assurances that what
you're doing is fair and
even-handed and that's I think a very
important question for Bob
Waller to answer I was not impressed for
this nine and a half minute disastrous
press conference this is going is not
going to be what the Democrats think
tell you that although Bob Muller is
people apparently according to Fox News
is breaking the subpoena is a friendly
subpoena he will only appear and stick
to the four corners of the report he's
not gonna say a thing